jd's just gotten into trouble uh with a
with a gang of of his friends and i mean
real trouble they
they bashed up things at a at a business
and um
were caught by the police and wrecked
mama's car
and mama has been in the hospital and uh
her daughter her other daughter comes
and tells her what you know that that
jd is basically running with the wrong
crowd of kids and
there's really no one who can save him
except mama
[Music]
hey hello
what are you doing this scene
i think is one that we did not rehearse
terribly
uh much when we all were together
uh two rehearse before we started
shooting
get your stuff she's tough and
i think whatever happened she would not
leave that house without jd with her
if you think you're hiding it honey
you're dumb as a bag of hair
pack up for what what are you doing
i'm taking him where to live with me
and if you've got a problem with that
you can talk to the barrel of my gun
it's really important for me to do to do
different things so that i'm creatively
challenged
but also i'm challenged by my own face
because i know
most people know it by now so when i
have a character like mama who's so
different from me in life
it was really important to me to change
my face
in subtle ways so that when i looked at
myself i didn't see myself anymore
i want to go
you want to go and live with her
i saw amy having met bev
figuring out how she was going to
do justice to the woman she met
and create a character because we're
we weren't trying to mimic people right
you're trying to do justice to the
essence of that person
so it's not about mimicking but it
there's something different
and and i i loved seeing
or feeling amy's
amount of thought i mean it's a strange
thing to say but she was like
she almost went into a another space
um where i could just feel her
kind of processing what she had heard
and making it her
own and i find that so moving because
it's such a craft
you know to be able to do that
she's crazy you know that she's been
crazy my whole life but if you want to
go live with that crazy old witch you go
right ahead you two are made for each
other
go and get your stuff
i think she wants a different life for
jd when
bev says she's been crazy my whole life
i think she's she's
thinking back to how you know it hasn't
been easy
and but mama
i think does not want to see that
pattern repeated
in her grandchildren you do that again
i'll leave you there
in life i think mama at one point when
she was young wanted to be a lawyer
you know again it was the culture they
were in
and and you know the circumstances of
their life that they
you know they didn't have the life that
maybe they would have wanted
so education for her was paramount
and this boy uh threw the calculator out
of the window
she pulls the card aside and she gives
him a real talking to
he's real tough and it's a a very
uncomfortable moment for him
now get out before i cancel your birth
certificate
get out and get that calculator
or don't bother getting back in i think
you see mama
kind of the essence of mamaw being her
tough love self
and also the one time that she had
admits
that she could have done better and she
feels i think great guilt about
bev about jd's mom
you're damn lucky that thing ain't
busted
if i weren't crippled i'd get out of
this car right now and i'd walk around
and i'd
smack your head and your ass together
why do you even want me
who said i wanted you i really hate you
you know that
i don't care you hate me i ain't in it
for popularity
you gotta take care of business you got
to go to school you got to get good
grades to even have a chance
mom was the best in her class what's the
point the point is
you don't know [ __ ] our trailers were in
macon georgia and on that day
they measured it at 140 degrees
around where the trailers were we were
in this car
this old you know vintage car with no
air conditioning
it's one of those scenes that i was
deeply insecure in
deeply insecure and i i'm trying to
learn from myself that sometimes as an
actor when i
do things that make me so insecure or so
uncomfortable is because that's how the
character is feeling
you know mama mama in that scene is
revealing things to jd that she maybe
never has
admitted to anyone while she's being so
tough with him
it was really one of those moments where
i said to
ron do you have do you think you have
what you need do you have it you need
because
you know and he said oh yeah i've got it
in space i have what i need
and um i think it's also from my theater
background right
that you want to have a perfect take
every single time
for getting in a film you can have
moments that are wonderful
um so i'm i'm always learning about
things like that
still i am so that's that scene for me
was
fraught um because it's a fraught scene
and it was very hot i thought your mama
was gonna be all right
be happy do good
but she got tore up around here she just
up and quit she just stopped trying
i know
i could have done better
but you you got to decide
you want to be somebody or not